Welcome, everybody.
Oh, that was loud.
Hi, I'm Claire Messud.
Welcome to this evening's
panel, The Words to Say it,
Teaching, Writing,
and Incarceration.
And I will introduce you to
our three wonderful panelists.
And then we might start
with a video clip.
And then we'll start talking.
So we have with us
today-- and I will then
explain a little about
how this panel came to be.
We have the writer
Richard Price,
who's the acclaimed
author of numerous novels
and screenplays.
His books include
Clockers, Lush Life,
and most recently
under the pseudonym
Harry Brandt, The Whites.
He's written many film and
television scripts, including
The Color of Money, Clockers,
The Wire, Freedomland,
and the Emmy-nominated
HBO series,
The Night Of, which
came out last year,
and which we'll be talking
about this evening.
And then Michelle Kuo
is next to Richard.
She is the author of Reading
With Patrick, A Teacher,
A Student, And A Life-Changing
Friendship, which
was published this summer.
She currently teaches in the
history law and society program
at the American
University of Paris
on issues related to race,
punishment, immigration,
and the law.
And she's taught at San Quentin
through the Prison University
Project, the only college degree
granting program at a state
prison in California.
Next to Michelle is Edison
Julio, a writer and prison
reform educator,
currently an urban scholar
in the Harvard School of
Education master's program.
He's a creative writing
instructor at Rikers Island
Correctional Facility
and a longtime teacher
in the CASES High
School Equivalency
Program, teaching inmates
and former inmates
of Rikers Island Prison.
CASES is the Center for
Alternative Sentencing
and Employment Services.
He also holds an MFA in fiction
from Hunter College, Cuny.
So and I'm Claire Messud.
I'm a fiction writer.
And well, you might wonder
what am I doing here.
So I wanted to
organize this panel,
as one hopefully among many
discussions about this issue.
And the way I came to this
is somewhat idiosyncratic.
Although two of the writers,
and if you count me,
are academically affiliated,
this is emphatically
not an academic panel.
It's a panel of teachers
and storytellers.
And the way this
came about is that--
well, the title
comes from a memoir
by a French writer named
Marie Cardinal, who
wrote a memoir
about psychoanalysis
called The Words to Say
It, in which she basically
is writing a book about
trauma and about the need
to find words for
experiences in order
to be able to process
and ultimately, hopefully
be free of those experiences, or
to transcend those experiences,
if not be free of them.
And it seems to me
that in there are many,
many ways to find
the words to say it,
but that each of these
participants on the panel
has been engaged in
telling the stories
or helping inmates tell their
stories of their experiences.
So I personally, first
in the trajectory
of how this panel came to
be, I last year watched
The Night Of when
the series was aired.
And whatever I might
have anticipated,
the series was something
else, and the series
proved to be the narrative
of a young man's journey
and transformation, a permanent
irrevocable transformation
at the hands of the
judicial system.
It is also a sort of
murder mystery story.
But that isn't actually--
it's many things.
And I'm sure the
story, that the series
is many things to many people.
But what my experience
of it as a viewer was,
was the psychological
investigation
into the transformation
of one young man.
And it was very powerful for me.
And then last winter, I read
Michelle's memoir in gallies.
And I had the good fortune
to work with Michelle when
she was in a fiction class
when she was in the law
school here some years ago.
And, in fact, she began this
book in Darcy Frye's class.
Darcy's here in the audience
and teaches nonfiction here
at the University.
And Michelle will tell
her story better than I.
But as my students from
last spring can attest,
when I read the book, I came
in, and I talked a lot about it
to the students, and every
time verklempt, [LAUGHS] right?
Every time.
I'm not going to tear up now.
But it too is the story of a
young man's transformation,
and your transformation
to, and perhaps
a more optimistic narrative
in a way than that
of Nasir Khan in The Night Of.
But the stories
are not unrelated.
And then in May--
so Eddie and I worked together
when Eddie was in the MFA
program at Hunter College.
And Eddie is a very
wonderful fiction writer.
But the way Eddie came into this
particular narrative for me,
is that last spring after
he was accepted, and awarded
this wonderful scholarship to
come here to the ed school,
Eddie organized a panel
at the ed school in--
was it after classes had ended?
It was a panel in for
which Eddie brought
a number of your students
or former l and also
Hakeem Browder, who is
the brother of Caliph
Browder, whose story
some of you may know.
But Eddie bill
will tell us more.
And these young men
were talking to--
I thought there would
be 1,000 people there.
But that's why I know it
was after classes ended
because there were a
lot of people there,
but there weren't
1,000 people there.
And those young men
were telling the stories
of their experiences.
And I was very powerfully struck
by some of the experiences
they articulated
had images for me.
And the images that
those experiences had
were from Richard's series.
And one of the things
that one young men spoke,
or more than one
young man spoke about,
was that when you first crossed
the bridge to Rikers Island,
what it feels like to be on that
bus, and to be full of fear,
and also to understand that
you can't be yourself anymore,
and that you have to put on--
it's almost like
putting on a costume.
You have to put on another
persona to move forward
into this unknown world.
So I thought we might perhaps
start with a video clip
from The Night Of.
I'm just going to move
because my head's--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- 43563, Hightower.
- That's what I expected, OK?
- Mr. Hightower, we meet again.
[BUZZER]
[SIRENS]
- Let's go.
[INAUDIBLE]
- Homosexual?
- No.
- On any meds?
- Ventolin for my asthma.
- Anything else?
- No.
You sure?
You're looking a
little walleyed there.
- I'm nervous.
- Suicidal ideations?
- Ideations?
- Are you thinking
about killing yourself?
- No.
- You in fear for your life?
- Should I be?
- You a civilian?
No gang affiliation?
OK, well, in that
case, good luck to you.
[END PLAYBACK]
So I thought that we might
start by you guys filling in
for us a little
bit, each of you,
about how you became
involved with these stories
in this world.
Richard, maybe you'd
like to tell us
first about how you came
to Nasir Khan's story.
m there's two things how I
came to Nasir Khan's story,
and how I came to Nasir Khan
as opposed to any one else.
Nasir Khan is Pakistani.
And the reason
why he's Pakistani
is because the original
in the BBC version,
it was the son of a cab driver.
And you're going to have
white cab drivers in London.
You're not going to have
white cab drivers in New York.
And so the first thing,
if the main character's
going to be son of
a cab driver, he's
got to be South Asian, or
Middle Eastern, or West African,
or some kind of Arab.
And my wife, who was working
on a book about Pakistan,
and had been to Pakistan
a number of times,
I went with her once to
Lahore and I left early.
It's tough for me, honestly.
But living with her, and
spending time with her friends,
I felt like of anywhere in
that world that I had any iota
of intimacy, or
not even intimacy,
of face-to-face contact
with, it was going to be--
I wanted my driver
to be Pakistani.
So you can blame my wife
for Riz Ahmed's success.
Anyways, so how did
I get to his history?
My experience with
prisons is basically
when I started doing Clockers in
1992, which is about basically
the crack world of Jersey City.
I started out with
police doing ride-alongs
with police, and
various agencies.
I spent time with m m
of mid-level dealers
on the street,
low level dealers.
And invariably,
that world is going
to take you to Hudson
County Correctional Center.
That was my first prison.
And I didn't do anything
there, but a company, the cops
to offload their collars
into the bullpen.
But I did know that
the building was
built in something like 1898.
It was that 900% capacity,
900%, which means
the gym was a sea of bunk beds.
There was a floor
where people should
have been in and in hospitals,
seriously needed meds.
And it was like a
row of tiger cages.
It was like the
valley of the damned.
These people couldn't even
live with themselves, let alone
anybody else.
And they were in
such the wrong place.
That was my first impression.
And that was '92?
No, that was more like '88, '89.
And I was asked
to teach a writing
class, a one-off writing
class at Sing Sing.
So I went up there and
I had some interactions
with the people that were in
the writing class, some of which
wanted to write, but most of
which wanted something good
in their jacket to speed
up the likelihood of them
getting an early release.
And that's just a fact.
And then I went to
the Santa Rita Jail
in Oakland, which is like the
cradle of the Black Panthers
to teach another class there.
And that was a story.
And then I had a young
guy when I was teaching
in a rehab program writing.
This kid was very talented.
He was not a drug addict,
but was smart enough
to say he had a drug
problem so he could
get into alternative
sentencing as opposed
to winding up on a prison barge.
And I had a mentorial
relationship.
And he went to jail one or
two times again and again.
And I would always
constantly go to visit him.
Ironically, my next
experience in jail
will be visiting one of the
producers of The Deuce, which
is a David Simon HBO
series that's on TV now.
He just wound up in jail.
That's another story
for another time.
But basically, what I'm trying
to say is my experience,
my personal experience
of prison is much less
than my two fellow speakers.
Basically, in and
out, in and out,
and a 30-year
friendship with somebody
who has been in and
out, and in and out,
and was very candid in
talking to me about it.
Thank you.
Eddie, how did you
come to first teach
at Rikers, Riker's inmates?
So before I answer
that question,
I'd like to ask everyone to
join me in a moment of silence
for those who've lost their
lives in prisons and those who
continue to be
ruined in prisons,
whether it's physically
or civically.
All right, so now to
answer your question,
how did I get
involved in the work?
When I was 10 years old--
so I live in the Bronx,
New York, born and raised.
When I was 10 years
old, I had a friend who
used to come over to the house.
He was much older than I was.
He was maybe 17, 18.
He was a good friend
of my brother's.
And he was athletic.
He was smart.
He was the kind of guy that kids
that were 10 would look up to.
And suddenly, he went
missing for some time.
And I was just curious about
what had happened to him.
And my brother was
hiding it from me.
So was my mom.
And then I had learned
he went to jail.
And I was curious
about what jail was.
I'm not sure how much I
knew about jail at the time,
but I know I didn't know much.
And so I had asked a
teacher about jail.
And the teacher
told me that that's
where all the bad people go,
as I imagine most teachers tell
their students.
But it just didn't
make sense to me,
because he was just
such a nice guy.
Again, he would buy us stuff,
he would take us to the store,
he was just cool.
We looked up to him, kind of.
Some time after that, he got
out of jail, fast forward four
years, and he killed himself.
And there was something
about the jail experience
that changed him forever.
After he got out of jail, he
was just different physically,
mentally.
He had just been-- jail wore
him down in every way possible.
And then that was
the first moment
when I became curious
with the institution
and what it was doing
to people in privacy.
And it's funny,
because this weekend I
went home to New York City.
And my mom for
some reason thought
it would be a smart idea
to tell my nephew that I
work in prisons and jails.
And so my nephew asked me.
My nephew asked me why I
want to work in a prison.
And he said that his teacher
had told him that that's
where all the bad people go.
And I didn't answer
his question then,
and I still don't think I know
the answer to his question now.
But yeah.
So that's how I
started doing the work.
How I got involved in Rikers,
a friend of mine's-- quick
story--
Reginald Dwayne
Betts-- he's a poet.
He's a great, great guy.
He did 10 years in state prison.
Now he's at Yale Law School.
They had commissioned
him to teach the course.
And he's kind of a big shot now.
So he was like, I can't do it.
I'm in DC doing big shot things.
But he said, but
I know this kid.
He's kind of smart.
Maybe he can do it.
And yeah.
He called me.
And I had already
been doing the work
for some time back
and forth doing
workshops at different
prisons, doing stuff at jails,
and teaching full time.
And so I took the
job, and that's
how I ended up on Rikers.
But so were you teaching
inmates or former inmates?
Were you teaching-- were you
working with the prison system
as it were from basically
right out of college
or even before then?
Yes, so even before then,
I was tutoring-- so I
was tutoring at a nonprofit.
So at the nonprofit,
I was working
with justice-involved youth.
So all of these kids had
either been to state detention
and were returning and trying
to earn their high school
equivalency diploma, or
had dropped out of school,
or had been on Rikers Island.
So I was tutoring in that
capacity and working.
And then I went on to work
full time at a nonprofit doing
the same work.
And then I started doing
in the prison stuff
and in the jail stuff.
So for the last 10
years, basically, I've
been working with the same
nontraditional students.
Thank you.
And Michelle, would
you tell us your story?
I will.
So I went here as an undergrad.
And I went to Arkansas,
rural Arkansas,
one of the poorest
counties in the country,
and like most people, I
I was very idealistic.
And this is a sign of my
middle class upbringing.
I never thought I would end
up teaching jail and teaching
in prison because I was
teaching in a school.
It was an alternative school
for kids who had been kicked out
of other schools.
And I have met this
student named Patrick, who
was 15 and in the eighth grade.
And he was really bright, really
quiet, broke up other fights.
And I was really crazy,
because I was 22,
and I was like, oh, Patrick's
not coming to school.
I'll just go to his house
and get him to come.
And education policy
is very complex.
But this actually worked.
One person telling him
to come to school worked.
And he started to
come to school.
And he loved silent reading.
Kids get a reputation
for being bad kids.
But so many of them
were just thirsting
for a quiet, peaceful
place to read.
At the end of these two years,
I'm in the middle of nowhere.
I'm thinking I'm
finally figuring out
how to do this thing.
I want to stay.
I'm going to stay for
a couple more years.
And my parents come to visit.
So I've been looking for
Asians in the audience
and racially profiling you.
So if any of you know
Taiwanese immigrant parents,
you know they're
not happy with me.
They're like why are you here?
Do you want to be
a teacher for life?
They are so afraid.
I sanitized some
stuff in my book
and took out some of the more
crazy things they said and did.
But they basically said you're
not our daughter if you stay.
And in some way, it's a
relief when somebody just
decides for you if you're
not sure what you want to do.
To be single in a rural
area is really hard.
I'm always joking
with my friends
that we need to start a
dating service in single areas
because then more
people would stay.
You just can't meet people.
So I decided to
come to law school.
And I've made promises
that I shouldn't have made.
I've told Patrick
that I'll stay.
I'll stay to see him
graduate from high school.
Fast forward to my third
year of law school,
and a friend of
mine calls and says,
you had Patrick as a
student, didn't you?
My first thought
is that Patrick has
died because there's such a
high mortality rate among youth.
It just doesn't occur to me
that it's something else.
And my friend told me that
Patrick had got into a fight
and killed someone.
And I was totally devastated.
And I didn't believe it.
I was like really shocked.
And now when I think
about it, I think
the shock is assigned to
my middle class upbringing,
because of course, the
most peaceful kids get
caught up and swallowed
up by poor neighborhoods.
So at the end of
these three years,
I've decided to do the lowest of
the low in the social hierarchy
of law school.
Legal aid, it's paid
less than, whatever.
It's paid less than
public school teachers.
And I think a lot of
the heart, the driving
engine of this book, was this
collapse of this idea of I
am a good person.
I think it's something a lot
of liberal, progressive think.
And I was like,
I'm doing legal aid
for undocumented immigrants.
I'm a good person.
But I just really felt like
my moral coherence fall
apart because I
wondered to myself,
if I had stayed in this rural
area, this place where people
of means leave both within
Arkansas and outsiders who
come, would this have happened?
I know it sounds like a
really arrogant question.
But if you live in
a rural area, you
know that relationships
matter, that people
are connected to one another.
And you know also
that all the studies
show that truants,
people who drop out
have the highest rate
of going into crime.
So I went back to see Patrick
to help him with his case.
He had been charged
for first degree murder
and he hadn't seen his public
defender who was overworked
with so many cases in Arkansas.
We started to talk
about his case.
I met with his public defender.
I tried to figure out
what happened that night.
And he didn't want to talk about
the legal defenses to his case.
This is also what
struck me, because I
had a lot of ideas for
legal defenses for his case,
but he wanted to hold on
to his story of his guilt,
that that was what
gave his life meaning.
He was deeply Christian.
And so we had to talk
about something else.
And that's when we started
to read and write together
every day.
And I just started going back.
And we were reading The Lion,
The Witch and The Wardrobe,
and Frederick
Douglass, and poetry.
And something that I
really ask in the book
is how is reading together
different from reading alone?
When we were reading
Frederick Douglass,
I was thinking to myself
that I was giving him
this American, black
American icon who
could attract tens of thousands
of people to these speeches,
and that Patrick would be moved
or uplifted by this example.
And that was wrong.
That was the wrong
idea to think about it.
Patrick was deeply moved
by scenes in which masters
give the slaves gin to prove
to them that they can't handle
freedom over the holidays.
And when Patrick read that,
he couldn't keep reading.
So there is a way in
which reading together
continually challenged
me, and it challenged him.
And by the end of
his time together, he
was writing these
extraordinary letters
to his daughter about
things he was reading,
things he was
imagining them doing.
The story doesn't end there.
That would be really
a more hopeful ending.
After he gets out
of jail after--
so we get the charge lowered
to manslaughter, which is good.
It's three to 10 years.
He gets out in three years.
But he can't find a job.
It's hard to find
a job in Helena.
It's hard to find a job
with a criminal record.
He has hundreds of thousands
of dollars of child support
debt that piles up in prison.
And so you can't
open a bank account.
And it was important for me.
It took me a long
time to even feel
I had license to
write this story.
But it's important to emphasize
that even though I feel
that I did change his
experience of incarceration,
I couldn't change the
systemic effects that
control his outcomes.
Yeah, so that's how I ended up
teaching in a rural county jail
in Arkansas, which had no
education program, no GED
programs, no mental
health counselors,
no re-entry programs, and where
he was held for 16 months.
I think that's what led
me to teach at San Quentin
Prison, which was the opposite
in terms of the resources
available.
You had hundreds of
volunteers every day
pouring in from Cal State,
from Berkeley, from Stanford.
And you felt like
you were really
part of this organized
team that was
offering an array of spiritual
programs, education programs.
And that abyss in terms of
the resources offered really
made me think about,
well, how do we
get rural areas, these people.
The community colleges
are an untapped resource.
But yeah, that's
how I got involved.
Thank you.
One thing I think that
is a common thread
is the youth of inmates.
And also-- and I remember Eddie,
it was something that came up.
I may get the statistics
wrong, but I remember
in the discussion in the
spring that there are--
is it 9,000 inmates in--
In Rikers, 8,000
inmates in Rikers.
89% of those inmates are
black and Latino men.
Of those 89%, 85% have
not been found guilty
of any criminal wrongdoing.
So they're just awaiting trial,
which is backed up years.
But that's not where
the story ends.
There's also a women's
jail on Rikers Island
that people never
talk about, Rosies.
There's 600 women at that
prison, at that jail.
I'm sorry.
Of those 600 women, 82%
are black and Latino.
Of that 82%, 75%
have been diagnosed
with a serious
mental health issue
versus 42% on the men's side.
And where it all takes
a twisted turn is
that of those 600 women,
65% are the sole caregivers
of their children.
And so those are the same
children that we ask, well, why
didn't you get into Harvard?
Why aren't you at Stanford?
Why aren't you at Yale?
65%, so that's good
old America for you.
So one of the things that
the film, that The Night Of,
this transformation of
this young man, it's
only really telling up to
the time of his trial, right?
It ends virtually
when the trial ends.
So the number of untried youth,
the transformation, when Eddie,
you talk about this
young friend of yours,
a friend of your youth
who came home transformed,
those are transformations
that are happening often
in the space of time before
there's ever any trial.
And so I wonder what,
aside from raising
awareness of these facts,
what can, as storytellers--
Richard, you've put the story
on the television in such a way,
on HBO in such a way that
people will watch it.
You guys have both
been teachers.
But how do we begin to address?
Is there is there a
way as storytellers
that we can begin to
address these issues?
So there was a time when
I was leaving Rikers,
and I was going home, and
I was writing fiction,
obviously, right?
My first aspiration
was to write a book.
But as we all know,
folks of color
can't do what we want to do.
We have inherited
the responsibility
to fight for everyone
else in our community.
Anyways, going home and
trying to write fiction
felt weirdly
self-indulgent, right?
It felt like, how am I
going from this place
where people are literally
killing each other,
and doing all these horrendous
things to live, to coming home
and imagining, and trying to
craft characters, and settings,
and plot.
And so it became a
competition for me between
should I be writing
essay or should I
be writing fiction, which
in retrospect feels silly
because the book that brought me
to the work in the first place
was a work of fiction.
It was Toni Morrison's,
The Bluest Eye.
And so that just
goes to show you
how fiction or writing
can bring us to the work
and can help change some stuff.
But to address it more
directly, the class
that I'm running on
Rikers now, if we're
talking about the transformation
and the performance,
is also a project that I'm
working on here at Harvard,
is this class that I call
Writing the Other Self.
Right
And the idea is
that on Rikers, they
have to put on this
performance, right?
It's a posturing of sorts.
So that's rarely ever
who they truly are,
but who they must
pretend to be if they
want to survive the place.
And so what I'm asking
them to do in this class
is to re-imagine themselves
outside of the inflexibility
of how they see themselves
in the jail, right?
And so we start by giving
ourselves a new name, right?
And it's all part of
creating this new identity.
And so a funny thing is,
I had a kid, Not a kid.
He's an adult. He gave
himself a French name.
And his name was Jean.
And we laughed at
him for a while.
But then I thought, shit,
this is interesting.
Wow, I'm wondering
where we can take this.
And I had another student
who said to me in the class
that he was wondering if I
could bring in an acting coach.
And I was asking, why do
you want an acting coach?
Am I not enough?
What's going on?
And what he said to
me was, well, I'm
interested in learning
new ways to walk,
new gestures, new voice
inflections, new tonalities.
They were really trying to
recreate themselves entirely.
Another part of the thing I
had them do is write scripts.
So while I am proud of urban
culture, and the ways we speak,
and the vernacular,
it's also deeply
problematic in some ways.
And I tell my
students all the time,
we can talk like that in here.
But you're not going
to get a job that way,
which is a whole
different argument
for a whole different time.
But anyways, so I have
them write new scripts.
And so I have them
write these dialogues.
And so I have to
pretend, pretend you're
talking to your mom, right?
How would you speak to her?
What are some new
words you would use?
And the kid that
named himself Jean
was trying to learn French.
And so this thing could stretch
out beyond anything that I ever
imagined it could be.
But that's the idea, right?
We've been given
these conditions, Now
how can we recreate ourselves
so that we can be a multitude,
so that we can be both the
person we have to be sometimes,
But the person
that we might want
to be in privacy or
away from everyone else,
away from the disasters,
away from the violence.
That's beautiful.
It makes me think.
Richard, how, just thinking
of the language, how did you,
you who are celebrated
for your dialogue
and for your ear for dialogue,
how did you find the language
for the prisoners in the film?
I just have them
talk like people.
I don't know.
it's not like how do you
talk in prison as opposed
to how do you talk
on Lennox Avenue.
People have lives before
they go to prison.
And that's the language
that they have.
So it sounds like there's this--
I'm going to do an Esperanto
quote, you know, prisonanto.
People in prison talk
just like people--
some are well
spoke, some aren't.
Some people speak in such
high speed in crowd vernacular
that I feel like
I want subtitles.
Some people, I wish
they would talk faster.
It's like I say about cops.
Cops are people.
There's assholes,
there's saints--
it wasn't like this,
is Solomon's rings
where King Solomon had
this magic ring where
he can understand the
language of birds,
and bees, and animals.
They're human beings.
Of course.
But I think one of
the things that is--
I suppose whatever
cabbie's son he'd been,
whatever family he'd come from,
your character who ended up
being Nasir Khan, we travel
with him into the prison.
And he's never been before.
And so he's learning
a whole new language.
And yes, people--
He's learning how
to verbally posture,
because it's part of
the survival strategy.
The tragedy of Kalief
Browder is multi-faced.
But what a young man, when he
comes into prison, if you want
to survive so different
than concentration camps,
if you want to survive,
you have to develop
to willing yourself
to survive, which
means do anything, be
ruthless, be alert.
And for those who can't
do that, you might die.
For those who can, it's a
horrible surgery on yourself,
because either you have to tap
into something inside yourself,
that you'd never
want to tap, and then
it makes you question the
whole nature of yourself
as opposed to your
public persona,
and you've got to pump
that up to the surface,
or you've got to do
this from scratch.
And at the end of The Night Of,
this Pakistani working class
kid who goes in, who's a
marketing student at Queens
College, he goes in there.
And he's a lamb.
And he comes out like half
wolf because he wanted to live.
And the question is that when--
or the issue is, when
he goes to his trial,
and people see a swarthy
kid with stubble head,
with tattoos on his neck,
bulked up, that's who he had.
That's who he had to become.
But now that he's
become that person,
how do you tuck that person
away once you walk out.
A lot of people say,
people in prison,
they feel like you
have two lives, one
before you go to prison, and one
after you come out of prison.
And even if you strive and
make something of yourself,
this is your prison
post prison life.
And it makes that kid
that you were a memory.
And it is actually something
that we see him physically,
that transformation that
we watch him physically
going through.
And he changes the
way he walks, right?
Well, it's like he's adapting.
He's adapting until-- his
adapting is such that even
he doesn't know who he is.
So in fact, at the end, you
don't even know if he did it
or not.
But you can believe
looking at him--
a lot of people--
I always thought
he didn't do it,
but a lot of people
reviewing the show
felt like, well,
look at the guy.
He was a thug all along.
And I just felt like, no.
This is what he's
become to live.
It doesn't mean-- well,
he was always this guy.
Can I just say one quick thing?
So I used to mentor
Kalief Browder.
And I remember one of the
very first conversations
we had after he got out of--
after he was off Rikers.
I would stay up
all night thinking
about what I wanted to ask him.
And I asked him, now
that you're off Rikers,
what are you afraid of?
And he said to me, I'm
afraid that I'll never
be the person I was
before I got there.
And then we all know
how that story ends.
He commits suicide.
But yeah.
I'm wondering, Michelle, whether
the experience of Patrick,
whether it's different,
whether it's the same,
or whether it's different
in certain ways because
of the circumstances,
the rural prison.
I don't know if
this was something
you were aware of,
that that sort of need
for a persona for
survival in the jail--
what were his circumstances?
Was he in a private cell?
So he was in a rural
county jail where it's
really different from Rikers.
He was transferred to a
place more like Rikers
after he took his
plea for manslaughter.
The rural county jail
has no organization.
It's cells without doors,
16 people in one place,
broken toilets everywhere.
The jailer also worked
part time at McDonald's.
I saw him there.
Another jailer was notorious
for mixing up meds that he gave,
no oversight whatsoever,
really, really different.
No budget, right?
No budget at all.
And the state of Arkansas
shut down that jail
several years later.
So if the state of Arkansas
is shutting you down,
that's a really bad sign.
And but everything
you're saying resonates.
Patrick changed after jail.
He was a different person.
You have to survive.
And I think also,
in Nas is innocent,
50% of state prisoners
have violent offenses.
And they're dealing with it.
They're traumatized
by it, traumatized
by what they've done.
And they don't have a
language to speak about it.
James Foreman and great--
Locking Up Our
Own, a great book.
He talks about how
liberals have ceded
the territory of vile offenses
to conservatives because they
know it's a losing battle.
We've been ceding
it for 20 years.
We focused on
nonviolent offenses
because it's a winnable issue.
It connects people.
Even a conservative
would think that 20 years
is too much for a
mere drug possession.
But we have violent offenses
that arise out of poverty.
And we have to talk.
We have to talk about them
and find ways for them
to feel that they're part
of a national discourse.
Black Lives Matter is
incredibly inspiring to me,
but it is rescuing
black innocents.
And Patrick's
story is about what
it feels like to be guilty.
And no matter how
many times I try
to explain to Patrick, like
sociological circumstances,
contacts, if you have
been born a different zip
code that would have happened,
he didn't want to hear it.
He needed to have his guilt
to have a sense of meaning
and free will.
So that's really powerful to me.
That was part of his
dignity to feel guilty.
So how do we break
that story gently?
It means telling more
stories of people
who want to make
sense of their crimes
and who have worthwhile lives
in spite of what they've done.
I would say, just a small
note, the transformation
isn't only Nas's alone, right?
There's this idea that
when we lock someone up,
or we imprison someone, that
it is an individual experience
and they're the only ones
undergoing the transformation.
And really what happens is
in some abstract and physical
and real ways when
you lock someone up,
you lock up their community,
you lock up their family,
you lock up their friends.
Just last month,
my two cousins had
to self-surrender to
the federal courts.
And I feel like I'm in prison.
I just can't speak
to them as much
as I used to speak
to them every day.
And you see it in the show.
His mother's ruined.
You see kids on Rikers.
His brother too.
Yeah, his brother.
You see kids on Rikers
walking through Magno meters.
Yeah.
That was the most powerful
part of the show is to me,
the Pakistani parents, the
mother starting to doubt.
And then once Nas lost
his mother's confidence,
it's like something in
him broke irrevocably.
That was very powerful.
The other thing, it's a
slightly different facet that
we're trying to
show with this show,
is [INAUDIBLE] had the
concept of the crab cage,
that where people,
if you put them--
take a bunch of crabs,
put them in a cage,
like a cylinder,
they'll reflexively,
when one starts to climb,
they'll reflexively--
another one will pull it down.
And so you could say that's
a bad crab for what he did.
He pulled that other crab down.
But how about the crab cage?
How about the divisors
of the crab cage?
And there's a villain in The
Night Of that has no name
and has no face.
And that's the personality
of the whole justice system.
You get into the system.
It's like there's a big cog
driven circular machine that's
caught the hem of your pants.
And it slowly just
pulls you in--
nothing personal, buddy.
I'm just a machine.
And you come out,
and you masturbated.
And who do you blame?
Do you blame the judges?
Do you blame the cops?
Do you blame the prosecutors?
Do you blame the alpha dogs
in the survival environment?
It's just this thing
that has no face.
And is inexorable.
And on the other hand,
you need a system.
But there's something-- if
you're trying to strike it,
where is it's face?
Where is its belly?
Where is its heart?
You're just-- and it's
just a grinding machine.
And everybody's a part of it.
And everybody's doing their job.
And it's just too big for
any-- is it an evil judge?
Is it evil?
It's this thing.
Eddie, did you want to--
I think yes.
I think the show is--
I think if you read this sort of
as a sociological text, what's
less important is what
happens, like the consequence
of the legal proceedings.
But I think one of the genius
things about oppression
is how--
well, one of the worst
things about oppression
is how genius it is.
The machine is just self
replenishing, right?
And I think what
the show is begging
us to do the entire time
is to look how it works,
like look at how this works.
And there's a great scene in
the last episode, I think it is,
where Nas is like, I'm free.
And he's just like,
all right, man.
Yeah, like I have to
be on the next call.
I have someone
else have to save.
I'll meet you there.
And you just never get a
moment to relax because that is
the nature of the beast, right?
It's just day and night
swallowing people up,
swallowing people up
disproportionately
who look like me, all right?
Well, and maybe we could
show this second clip.
And there are
issues that come up,
because one of the
things, one of the issues
that came up in the
discussion in the springtime
was about the entire community,
and that often the people who
are the guards or who
are working in the prison
come from the same
communities as the inmates.
Well, that's how people in
prison in my experience, what
I've learned is that
the guy said, well, how
can this guy become a kingpin?
He's in prison.
Everybody else has weapons.
He's a skinny guy.
Well, he starts out--
he has pull in the
outside world, which
is probably the reason
why he's in there
because in an enterprise.
All these guys, they grew
up together, the guards.
And everybody knows
where everybody lives.
So guards will kowtow
to some of these guys
because they don't want
somebody to fuck up their wives
or show up at the
quinceanera with an uzi
at their 15-year-old
kid's party.
So I mean--
That's the clip actually that--
Yeah.
That's the clip we're going to--
I just blew that one.
No, you didn't.
[LAUGHTER]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Have a seat.
- That guard, Tito?
His daughter's having a
quinceanera this weekend.
That's her sweet 16, only 15.
But the dude live
in Brownsville, man,
as shitty a hood as they come.
So I said, man, you
should be concerned
about the local thugs
crashing the thing,
getting high, fighting.
The next thing you know,
somebody's squeezing off shots,
don't care who they hit.
I said, I couldn't
guarantee that won't happen,
but I could make
a few phone calls,
see if I can help out with that.
That's what that little
thank you is for.
You see, us--
- Have a seat.
- That guard, Tito?
His daughter's having a
quinceanera this weekend.
That's her sweet 16, only 15.
But the dude lives
in Brownsville, man,
as shitty a hood as they come.
So I said, man, you
should be concerned
about the local thugs
crashing the thing,
getting high, fighting.
The next thing you
know, somebody's
squeezing those shots,
don't care who they hit.
I said, I couldn't
guarantee that won't happen,
but I could make
a few phone calls,
see if I could
help out with that.
That's what that little
thank you is for.
You see, us and the guards,
we all from the same hood.
Some of us even
grew up together.
They know our families.
We know theirs.
Family's everything, right?
It is in a Muslim family.
- Yeah.
- Let me tell you
something, man.
See those brothers you pray
with, the Nation of Islam?
They're not your friends.
In fact, they hate your ass
because you're a natural born
Muslim, and they're just
phony jailhouse opportunists
looking for better food.
Don't know the difference
between Cairo, Egypt, or Cairo,
Illinois.
- I'm Pakistani, not Egyptian.
- Yeah, well my ancestors came
from Dahomey and not the Congo.
Who gives a fuck, man?
So you're a celebrity in here.
And I'm not talking
the good kind.
Dude kills four
guys over some dope.
OK.
But murder a girl?
Rape a girl?
- I didn't.
- Doesn't matter.
Makes no difference.
See, there's a whole separate
judicial system in here,
and you've just been
judged and juried.
And it didn't come
out good for you.
- Close your eyes.
Close your eyes, I said.
- Give me your hand.
Don't be afraid, Nasir.
- Feels good, right?
Like silk?
- It's meat.
- You wish.
It's somebody's heart.
[LAUGHS] Yeah, it's meat,
but the best kind, veal.
You people eat veal, right?
- Sometimes.
- But only blessed, right?
I respect that.
- Thank you.
- Listen to you,
all polite and shit.
See, the reason
it feels like silk
is because on the day it's born,
they keep it in a dark crate,
so small, it can't
even turn around.
And it stays there, half blind
in the dark, drinking baby
formula, waiting to die.
- There are some bad people in
here, but I could protect you.
Nasir, do you want
my protection,
or do you prefer
dead in the shower
with your brains bashed
in, guts on the floor?
It's up to you.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
I just wanted to say one
thing about that scene
in the context of what
we're talking about, is
that scene was written.
That scene was
much more composed
and eloquent than in real life.
So what you were looking
at was fictional drama
to get across a certain point.
But the goal of it was also
to fascinate and to entertain.
And I doubt there are many
scenes like that in real life.
And I just want to draw that
distinction between what
everybody is saying
and the artifice
of writing a television show.
Hopefully, you're
getting an essence out.
But I can't imagine that scene
going down your line by line
in prison, in real life.
What fiction gives
you, well, fiction
is artificial by nature.
But it takes the chaos of
life in a certain environment,
say, prisons.
And it forces a shapeliness
on its delusion of reality.
And in this way,
sometimes they say
fiction is more powerful
than nonfiction and reality
because it steers you to
comprehension in a way life is
too random to do.
Life is not neat.
That was neat, that scene.
I don't mean neat like fun.
I mean people were laughing.
The actors were fantastic.
But just fiction
sometimes nudges reality
into a recognizable
shape for a lesson.
I just wanted to say that.
The other thing I wanted to
say about that Harvard t-shirt
since we're here, the whole
point of the Harvard t-shirt
is that when he was
arrested, at the precinct,
his clothes were all
taken by the crime scene
unit for forensic processing.
And they basically gave him the
bullpen equivalent of scrubs.
So he's walking
around, like an intern,
or a person whose clothes had
been completely taken away
from him.
And one of the detectives
there, trying to seduce him
into speaking says here.
And there's always this random
pile of clothes at a precinct.
And he gives him the
clothes, so when he goes in,
when he goes further,
he doesn't look
like he's just been stripped.
And he ironically winds up with
a Harvard shirt The double down
ironic--
and I told this to one of the--
my friend who was in and out for
30 odd years out of 45 years.
He said, well, here's
what's going to happen
with that Harvard shirt.
He's going to have to
take it off immediately.
It's a gang color.
So I don't know if you're
Crips or Bloods out there,
but you're Harvards.
I think the question
of fiction and what
it can do both in telling--
imagining.
Eddie, your students, imagining
the stories of their lives,
and, Richard, you
imagining, say,
Nas's story, the possibilities
of fiction I think
are what I keep coming back to.
And I wondered,
Michelle, whether, just
to make sure we have it out
there, because you might read
one of the things that
Michelle asked Patrick to do
was write letters
to his daughter.
And I wondered if you
might just share with us
the first one and the last one.
Oh, yes.
I'd love to.
Yeah, so I wrote
nonfiction, and I
was really embarrassed at
the idea of writing a quote,
unquote "memoir."
For the longest time when people
asked me what I was working on,
I'd be like, it's a
mixture of law and history
about the rural south because--
I don't know-- I think it's hard
to place yourself on the page,
and to own the difference
in equality between yourself
and another person.
So here is the first letter
Patrick wrote to his daughter.
His daughter's name is
Cheri, or cherished.
"Hey, Cheri, I know
I'm not in your life.
It'd be my fault. It hurt
me I ain't there with you.
Here, people be arguing about
nothing and trying my patience.
Sitting here doing
nothing, but how messed up
I am thinking of you.
Love, your daddy.
And this is after he's
worked intensively
reading, and writing,
and being fully absorbed.
He's reading in a concrete
stairway that has no light.
People steal his stuff, but
not his books or notebooks.
Whenever I leave books
of them, I'm always like,
are people going to take these?
He's like, they're not
going to take this.
And this is at the end
of our time together.
"You and I are canoeing
down the Mississippi River.
There are so many
trees, bunched together
in the water like bushes.
The river is shadowy
in some places,
but the light shines
through cracks of the trees.
Near the bank, there's a great
blue heron standing still,
searching for fish.
And as we are
passing, a silver carp
surfaces as if it is
jewelry in the water.
You say, Dad, look, a snake.
I say, where?
And you say, no,
it's just a vine.
We hear splashes.
The white light glitters
on the muddy water, which
you say looks like coffee.
When we approach the thick
of cottonwoods and cypress,
we can hear birds.
On some low branches hang
plenty of mulberries.
You stretch your arm
straight out to grab some.
They are white because
they are not ripe yet.
But the edible ones
are bluish black.
You see on it it
stains your shirt.
As we roll away, I tell you
that whenever we are at home
and you take a nap, I think
of you as a sleeping berry.
It's amazing to
see trees grow out
of the water in so
many different shapes.
Some have a Y shape and
others are lying down.
The willow trees
are so tall that you
can hear our necks
cracking while we
are looking for the top.
To the left, it's
a floating log.
And suddenly, I see it
has two turtles on it.
We watched the Turtles
until they jump off.
You want to feel the
water too, so you
can put your foot outside
the canoe and into the river.
I could see it dangling under
the surface like a little fish.
I'm sitting at the
bow with my hands
behind my head mesmerized.
If the wind blows and
the tree leaves shake,
it sounds like rattling paper."
When I have read
that to my students,
I say if everybody
could write like that,
we wouldn't need a
writing class, right?
He's a beautiful writer.
And I'm also struck
because, Eddie,
what you were saying about
with your students imagining,
imagining who they want to be,
who the other self would be.
And I recall that Patrick
had not been canoeing.
Is that right?
He had not been canoeing
on the Mississippi.
No.
He wanted lots of pictures,
pictures of Mississippi,
and Arkansas.
There's a moment in
Clockers that I really
love where the kids are just
going through catalogs, just
to look at the pictures.
And that's how it was
whenever I brought
in anything with pictures
of Arkansas and Mississippi.
And it's interesting when we
have an idea of a rural area.
We think people are really
connected to the land.
But they often aren't
because large multinational
corporations own thousands
of acres of land.
So they aren't
connected in a way.
And there is no opportunity
to go on the river,
and explore, to take swimming
lessons, or anything like that.
I don't mean to
cut you off though.
No, no, no.
I just wanted to say a thing
about the fiction stuff.
So I was trying out the
writing the other self thing
with both inmates and with
folks that I was working
with outside of the gym, right?
So they had access
to worldly things.
It was interesting because I had
this one student who was really
enjoying the exercise, right?
And so he had given
himself a new name.
He had been spending time
with this new identity.
And then one day he came
to me and said, Eddie,
but I can't
fictionalize a felony.
And so then
suddenly, now there's
a whole new layer
to this problem.
And that's why it's hard
to think about it outside
of the person without
considering also
the system that is
invested just as much
in making sure that these
kids aren't doing well.
And I had no answer for that,
because there is no answer,
because I've had students
who've gone on interviews
and haven't gotten
the jobs, or course,
for private organizations
because they had records.
But a thing I will say about
the fiction, the fiction
stuff, and some of the
possibilities of writing
the other self is that
it's like a thing that--
so Colum McCann was one of the
professors I had at the MFA.
And Coolum McCann, whenever
we were workshopping a story,
would stop abruptly and ask,
would this character use make--
would this character
wear makeup,
or would this character travel?
If so, where would
this character travel?
And Colum was
never really asking
because it was important
for the narrative.
Colum was only asking
because he wanted
to make sure that me, the
person writing the story,
knew the character that
I was writing intimately.
And so one of the things
I've had my students
do is give the person that
they're creating hobbies,
right?
What would this person do?
I want you to know
the person intimately.
And I had one of my students
come back to me and said,
I went to the museum this week.
And this kid had never left
Brownsville in his entire life
maybe.
That is, for many of us--
I'm from the same
place they are--
that is the extent of our
world sometimes, unfortunately,
unfortunately in some ways.
It's a beautiful place.
But yeah, so he had
went to the museum.
And so I'm curious about what
happens, as you fictionalize
this new identity,
when you inhabit
this space or the person,
and get to know the person,
and spend more time
with the person,
and do things that
person would do.
So I see how it works.
And then I see how
it doesn't work.
Yeah.
Well, there are lots of things
swirling in my head right now.
And as you say, you can't
fictionalize a felon,
one of the things that's
swirling in my head
is that I believe in France
with the Napoleonic Code.
Once you've purged your
crime, it cannot be mentioned.
And that is a very
different approach, right?
You have purged your crime.
It's literally seen
as it's expunging.
And it's gone.
And how different it is here,
and that the narrative is not
one that actually allows
for rehabilitation, really.
It doesn't.
In this summer--
so another thing.
This summer I revisited
the Albert Camus,
and I read The Stranger,
which is really good,
but for other reasons.
And one of the things
that happens in that book,
there's an interesting
thing where
the narrator or the
protagonist is--
so he spent some time in jail.
And one of his hobbies
becomes to imagine himself
on the beach, or imagine
himself outside of the place.
But what you find happens after
some time in jail or in prison
is that he becomes
so deeply affected,
that the only thing he
can imagine are like--
or he can't even imagine
anymore, that the only thing he
can think of are
activities that he
was doing within the
boundaries of the actual jail.
And I've had students tell
me on Rikers or at prisons
I don't have an imagination.
I've asked students in
prisons or on Rikers,
what do you want to be
when you get out of here?
What are some of
your aspirations?
And I hope there's not
a plumber in the crowd.
But what I've recognized,
I'm going to say,
is that like most of them have
lost that capacity to dream,
right?
I want to be a plumber.
Yeah, maybe I'll be
a security guard,
or maybe I'll be a technician
or something like that.
And it's just like, what happens
to the imagination in jail?
And this is not
happenstance, right?
This isn't a coincidence.
This is a pattern that I've
recognized in this place.
Yeah, so--
Is that something, Richard?
Do you think that when you--
maybe you don't imagine further
for your character.
But if you do, do you imagine
that his sense of the possible
is curtailed by his experience?
Permanently curtailed?
He comes out where he
might have seen mountains.
Now he sees plains.
And I think he's so
conditioned to fight or flight,
and outsmarting someone
in order to survive,
or his manipulation has become--
he's been manipulated
by his environment
into thinking of constant
manipulation as a way of life.
He can't get the prison
smell off his brain.
And it's kind of corny,
but I always remember,
I think when sometimes fantasy
is on scale with the reality,
which is to say if your becomes
like a just vicious phone
booth, crowded phone booth,
your fantasy is not someday
I'll fly an airplane.
Your fantasy is maybe
if I move this way,
I'll have another
free pocket of air,
because this is your world.
I remember, in one of
the Sholem Aleichwm,
Gimple the Fool, who was a pure
soul, finally goes to heaven.
But he's been very
poor his entire life.
He's done nothing but
pogroms and deprivation.
But because he's such a simple
soul, he gets to heaven.
And God asks him when he
comes to heaven, Gimple,
welcome to heaven.
The angels, the angels
are at your disposal.
You can have anything you want.
You can live the life
you always dreamed of.
And Gimple says
anything I want, can I
have a hot cup of tea every day?
It's just you're like this.
So your fantasies within
this, how to get up one--
so a guy like--
a guy like Nasir, maybe
he'll bounce back,
or maybe he'll just have that
predatory manipulative survival
head, and it'll get him
into greater trouble.
Number one, the last thing
you see, he's a junkie.
And but it's open.
He's young.
It's openended.
So who's to say?
That's why they
call them serials.
Maybe it's a good time to
ask if there are questions
from the audience,
if there's anybody
who'd like to ask a question.
Sir?
So religion has come up a
number of times in this panel.
And I see it--
Do I have a microphone?
There is here.
Thank you.
Hello?
Is this on?
No, maybe it was on.
Can you hear me?
So religion plays a double-edged
role I think in society.
And we've seen it come up a
number of times in this panel.
It provides a liberating
spiritual cultural cultivation
for some, and it
oppresses others.
At the same time, Christian
theology and language
has historically
played a huge role
in the production of this
punishment enterprise
that we live with in
our society today.
So it's a double fold question.
So it is what role do
you see from the outside?
What ethical and
moral role do you
see academics,
writers, activists,
religious practitioners,
politicians, et cetera
in challenging society,
especially linguistically,
because that's come up a
number of times as well
to restructure our systems
and reframe the response?
That's where all the
bad or evil people go.
And what role do you
all see religion playing
within the confines of
the punishment facilities?
Who would like to tackle one of
those questions, [INAUDIBLE]??
Oh, you're fine.
I've been thinking
about this, actually.
I've been thinking about your
question, the second part,
because I've been thinking about
parts I left out of the book
and why I unconsciously
left them out.
So I had a question when
I was in Mississippi
talking about the book
and a white woman.
Heard the story.
She's lived in the
delta all her life.
She knows the delta.
She said, is Patrick
grateful to you?
I felt so uncomfortable.
And everybody who wasn't
from the delta was like, uh,
grateful?
He's the one who's been
born in the wrong zip code,
and struggled, and want to the
worst schools in the country.
I am just a small speck
in this large picture
of systemic inequality, right?
That's how I've been
trained to think
at a progressive institution.
So I started to say this.
And then I just heard
this lecturing tone.
It's like, she's the
one who lives here.
She knows what the
delta [INAUDIBLE]..
She's seen the out migration
of all the bright kids.
So then I just like--
I was like, well,
what is the question?
The question was,
was he grateful?
Yeah, he was intensely grateful.
He's a Christian man.
Gratitude is the
most holy virtue.
He was extremely thankful.
He called me an
angel all the time.
I always was like, no.
I try to explain to
him I didn't agree.
But I took that out of the book
because it's so uncomfortable.
I didn't take out all
of his Christianity,
but I didn't want to
be seen as a savior.
I didn't want him to
be seen as unrealized
in terms of understanding
his inequality.
We have a secular
narrative that somebody
who believes that has
false consciousness.
You know that he
doesn't really know
how oppressed he is, that I
knew that there would be--
my editor took out this letter.
He said thank you,
[INAUDIBLE] call me an angel.
It's interesting.
It's a question about the writer
intuiting what the readers will
tolerate and what they won't.
And it's powerful
to think about.
The reader would tolerate that
a bright African-American man
would end up in jail within
three years of dropping out
at 15.
And they would tolerate this
history of white supremacy.
But they wouldn't
tolerate belief
in angels, which
reflects his world, where
he's very close to the dead.
His mother passed away
soon after he got out.
So it's interesting.
It's a really important
question because religion
is so important to
a lot of prisoners.
When I taught at San
Quentin, my husband
is a religious
historian, started
teaching about the Bible.
And the students didn't
want to read book of Job
as an angry god.
They didn't want it.
One student walked out.
And it was like my
first lesson of you
have to understand where
students are coming from.
You can't take away their faith.
You have to understand
where it comes from.
So I'm glad you asked.
I'm still working through it.
I'd love any help answering.
Steve.
So I'm still-- so real quick,
so other folks can ask.
I'm still working through
that question myself.
But what I will say is this.
And this is something I've
been thinking about a lot.
We often think about the
perpetrators of the crime
and what they deserve.
But the problem is, I've
known so many of the perps,
but I've also known the victims.
And so when we're
thinking about justice,
when we're thinking
about mercy, when we're
thinking about
Christianity, I think
everyone deserves a fair shake.
And so it's hard now to try
to play the judge, right?
What does this person deserve?
He killed someone's son, right?
He killed someone's cousin.
He killed someone's
older brother.
And I think the direction--
I think, so you take
out the emotion.
The smart direction
to move in is,
because I've also seen this
side of it, there's just no--
it makes no sense
then to take someone
who committed such
a crime and then
put them in a
prison for 25 years
because then everyone
loses, right?
And so I think that if we want
to think about it sort of--
if we want to think about
what works for the community
and what works for
society, then that I feel
might be the smartest
direction to think in.
But the Christian question is
a tough one and a tricky one
because there's a few different
ways, a few different things
to consider.
It may or may not
be in response.
But I'm just thinking.
I remember going to a
friend's son's bar mitzvah
where he was speaking about--
the text that he was speaking
about was from Genesis.
It was Adam and Eve, and
the snake, and the apple.
And it was not--
I was raised a fairly
passive Christian.
But it was not
original sin, right?
In Talmudic study,
right in Judaism,
that moment in
the Garden of Eden
is the necessary
growing into adulthood
and self-consciousness
of humanity, right?
It's not it's not
a terrible failure.
It's the beginning.
And I was so struck by it.
This was many years ago.
But I was so struck by it
because it had never occurred
to me to think of
it any other way.
And I think one of the
things that underlies,
is part of your
question, is there
some way in which we as a
culture could profitably
examine our underlying
narratives that have determined
everything and continue
to determine everything
going forward, and just
thinking in terms of say that
a French notion that
you can purge a crime
and then begin again,
as opposed to one
that you are falling into a
state of sin, which is always
awaiting you, and that from
which you can never emerge.
Those are very different ways
of understanding the world.
I don't know.
Yes, ma'am?
A microphone comes.
It was very
interesting to hear all
of you ruminating or pondering
on this theme of suffering.
So what struck me throughout
the whole panel discussion,
or this lecture, I was hearing
about in the back of my head,
the problem of the immigrants,
and the suffering that
an immigrant-- this is
a very common theme--
everyone goes through.
And all kinds of suffering,
I was thinking of partition,
I was talking Holocaust,
I was thinking
of all kinds of suffering.
And so what is the difference?
I know there is a difference
that you folks wanted
to bring it in your discussion.
And listening to this,
and also all the victims
of British
colonization, there is
a book by a very [INAUDIBLE]
Indian philosopher
Sri Aurobindo.
The book is called
Tales of Prison Life.
And the jail cell that
was depicted in this film
reminded me of that.
So anyway, going back,
also, I was thinking--
May I ask, do you
have a question?
Yes.
The question is,
where do you draw
the line between the suffering
and the lack of which
causes the lack of imagination?
And how do you
transcend that, because
like the John who made
up his French name,
and they are imagining.
And you also mentioned
more reasons.
I was thinking of Beloved.
So there is--
I hear at the same
time this concern
for the lack of imagination.
They forget to imagine,
and big things.
And also but some
people do still
try to construct
their own world.
So where is that boundary, or
how do they overlap or cross
the boundary?
Does somebody want
to answer that?
But how do you--
I'm not sure I
understand the question.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
I'm not trying to dodge you.
I'm just not sure I understand.
The question is how do
you cross the boundary
between lack of imagination?
Because by suffering too
much, they forget to dream.
But at the same time, they have
this also the inner tendency
to overcome the suffering.
So--
So I think that this--
so all right.
So I would say this, all right?
There is a way where it
impacts certain inmates
and their imagination
suffers, right?
And then they're incapable
of imagining sometimes.
But I would say that
some of the greatest
innovation I have ever
seen in my entire life
has been in jail.
I have watched my
inmates make alcohol
from sleeping pills and water.
I have watched my inmates
build small contraptions
to find ways to lock out
after the CO locked them in.
My inmates found a way
to clean the toilet bowl.
So they got the meat,
and kept it there.
It was like a
makeshift refrigerator.
My inmates, they
wanted to smoke, right?
So what they did was they took
the lead from the pencils.
And they found out that if you
attach it to the battery end,
you can spark a fire.
And so it's never
been a question
about academic aptitude
or imagination.
I think these are the
most brilliant folks.
But what happens is that
not everyone can persist.
Not everyone can go on that way.
And then just some people, some
people give into that pressure.
So if I think you're
asking the question I'm
thinking you're asking,
it's very individual,
like case by case, right?
I know people who have
done 15 years in jail
and have done eight years
in solitary confinement,
and I know someone who did three
years in solitary confinement
and took his own life.
It affects everyone
very, very differently.
And then some leave
and can't imagine.
But then some leave
propelled, right?
And some leave ready
to imagine in ways
that they've never imagined.
Some people say to me
jail was the best thing
that ever happened in my life.
But some people
say jail killed me.
Maybe one last question.
Yes, ma'am?
OK.
Eddie, thanks a lot
for your presentation.
I think you are raising
a lot of issues.
Sorry.
Another thank you.
[INAUDIBLE],, thanks a
lot for your presentation
and all of you.
But, Eddie,
specifically, I thought
you were raising some
interesting tensions that
exist among the panelists
around the question of writing,
but also thinking from
particular positionalitites.
And one of the
things that I thought
that you were
bringing up a lot was
that notion of the guilt that--
was it you that was
talking about the guilt?
Michelle spoke [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, Michelle.
OK, and I wanted to
connect it to this.
So this notion of the built
where Patrick is constantly
feeling that, and in
a way, constrained
within a certain kind
of effective economy
that has been
already constructed
for particular people
more than others.
So I wanted to conjunct this too
because Michelle was bringing
yup the white sensibility, what
it means to be a middle class
person working with people.
But that is bringing
from the vantage point
of being black, and recognizing
that the majority are
black and Latino people.
So maybe speak a little
bit to that tension.
And how do you rapture these
dominant, effective economies
that really log in particular
populations more than others.
Does one of you
want to start there?
Sure.
So the question is more about
the tensions between perhaps
mine speaking for more of
an outsider standpoint and--
[INAUDIBLE]
But Eddie was putting himself
in in a very different way
that you were, the positionality
and [INAUDIBLE] structure.
So speaking to that
a little bit more,
because I think it speaks to the
tensions in terms of writing,
since we talk
about writing here,
but also in terms of how
do you really rapture
this dominant
[INAUDIBLE] economies
from different positionalities.
Yeah, it's really hard.
When I went to
Arkansas, look, anybody
know how many
Asian-Americans or Asians are
in Phillips County, Arkansas?
One, me.
OK, no there were the Chinese
guys who own the restaurant.
I would go say hi.
But they're from China.
My parents are from Taiwan.
So I was definitely an outsider.
There was no question.
People would stare.
I was very conspicuous.
My kids, to get under my
nerves, would be like,
are you related to Jackie Chan?
And I'd be like, no,
I'm actually not.
Being a [INAUDIBLE] was really--
it's fine.
I don't take whatever
microaggressions.
I don't care.
In a rural area, I'm the one
who has the resources to leave.
Immigrants don't go to
rural areas to get jobs.
So I didn't take it
personally at all.
So I was definitely
outsider, but sometimes I
get upset when people were
like, why don't you just go back
to where you're from?
Where am I from?
I'm from a place where I was
also an outsider in Kalamazoo,
Michigan.
And my parents never taught me
anything about townies history
because they grew up in
an authoritarian regime
where they couldn't learn
about their own histories.
Taiwan has been colonized
for four centuries.
So it's confusing
because I'm constantly
aware of that power dynamic.
I would rather there be
African-American educators
in schools and in prisons.
But I wouldn't force
them to do that.
They should go do
whatever they want to do.
You know what I want?
More Asian-Americans
to participate,
to feel solidarity,
to put themselves
at risk, to own the pain,
because, like you said,
we're all part of this complex.
So it was hard for me to
write because I understood.
I tried to understand
positionality.
I wanted to be honest about it.
I didn't hide from it.
I had a Post-it
note on my computer
that said stop
hiding, because I was
hiding beneath the outrage of
this history that is grotesque.
But you have to put
yourself on the page.
You have to put the
inequality on the page
and work through it.
The one--
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
Go for it.
Yeah.
So positionality is something
I think about a lot.
I think the biggest credit,
the reason I've been most--
I think the reason I've been
successful in the classroom
with these specific students
is because I believe very, very
firmly that it is not
only enough to reflect
the physical likeness of the
students, or in other words,
just because a black person
walks into the classroom
doesn't mean by virtue of that
you're going to learn from me.
But it means so much more
to reflect the likeness
of their character, right?
Because when they have
someone in the classroom who
has tattoos, who gestures the
way they gesture, who speaks
the same language
that they speak,
it becomes the meeting
place between aspiration
and what's practical, Or
in other words, they think,
oh, Eddie's doing this,
and Eddie's like me.
So maybe that means I can do it.
You get it?
And so that's the
biggest credit.
The problem is not everybody
could pull that off.
But--
[LAUGHING]
[INAUDIBLE]
This may be a good moment
to end our discussion.
[APPLAUSE]
I want to thank Richard Price,
Michelle Kuo, and Edyson Julio.
[INAUDIBLE]